die schlimmsten prognosen sind
eingetreten und es zeigt sich dass das
mit panikmache rein gar nichts zu tun
hat 100 2000 verdachtsfälle und die
behörden in china scheinen mit dem
erfassen nicht mehr hinterher zu kommen
während sich die verdachtsfälle
verzehnfacht haben sind die bestätigten
fälle in 48 stunden lediglich um 4000
gestiegen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation hat den
internationalen gesundheitsnotfall
erklärt mehr als 200 menschen sind
inzwischen an dem corona virus gestorben
hier die aktuelle entwicklung pixum
science und fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
ich halte die kategorien panik oder
panikmache bei einer pandemie für
vollkommen falsch
ihr könnt euch also eure kommentare
sparen man kann die leute auch nicht in
trügerischer sicherheit wiegen denn
schon jetzt ist klar
atemmasken sind weltweit ausverkauft für
alle die bisher entspannt waren gibt es
im moment kaum noch eine möglichkeit sie
zu bekommen fakt ist hier in deutschland
wird steht so gut wie keine gefahr zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt das kann aber in ein
paar tagen schon anders sein
dem sollte man sich zumindest
bewusstsein dass es eine solche pandemie
geben kann
das ist schon lange bekannt und es
könnte halb diese oder eine andere sein
nur man sollte achtsam sein und
vorsichtig die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who hat
nicht zum spaß weltweite
verhaltensregeln veröffentlicht für
instagram haben wir sie auf deutsch
übersetzt und gepostet der link ist hier
unter bitte befolgt sie der britische
biologe neil ferguson vom imperial
college london hatten vor vier tagen
nämlich recht er vermutete 100.000
infizierte
das große problem nämlich ist anders als
bei saas sind menschen schon anstecken
wenn sie keine symptome haben und das
ist fatal laut ferguson steckt eine
infizierte personen bis zu drei weitere
menschen an
zitat meine beste schätzung ist aktuell
das ist schon 100.000 fälle gibt so
ferguson zum guardian das war vor vier
tagen und jetzt sind 100 2000 menschen
als verdachtsfälle er fast zehnmal so
viel wie noch vor zwei tagen demnach
könnte die steigerungsrate viel höher
sein als bisher vermutet es gibt rund
10.000 bestätigte fälle und 200 tote das
ist alles fatal für china british
airways und die lufthansa haben den
flugverkehr dort hin deshalb eingestellt
im rest der welt ist die lage momentan
noch eine ganz andere doch china zeigt
welches potenzial in diesem erreger
steckt
und das obwohl die maßnahmen drastisch
waren sie wurden nur viel zu spät
ergriffen erst in den nächsten tagen
werden wir sehen ob sie gegriffen haben
die whu befürchtet jetzt dass in anderen
ländern die vielleicht nicht so gut
vorbereitet sind nicht so toll elitär
organisiert sind ein ausbruch die
gleichen folgen haben könnte und eben
schlimmer in china hat mit nur einer
handvoll patientinnen und patienten
alles angefangen so viele wie es jetzt
in thailand 14 sind es dort und
australien 9 gibt und auch bei uns in
deutschland gibt es schon die zweite
erkrankung bei der der betroffene nicht
von der chinesischen kollegen angesteckt
wurde sondern von einem mitarbeiter der
sich wiederum bei der chinesen
angesteckt hatte und der hat wiederum
sein kind angesteckt ein kind das
mutmaßlich in eine schule oder in einen
kindergarten geht also sehr viele andere
kinder anstecken kann sprich auch in
deutschland ist es schwer die
infizierten zu isolieren selbst wenn wir
eine der besten medizinischen versorgung
der welt haben infizierten ohne symptome
die als verbreiter umherlaufen kann
dieses system auch nicht aufspüren bola
2014 bis 16 gab es eine super vor
weiteren eine heilerin bei deren
begräbnis hunderte besucher und
besucherinnen ihren körper anfassen und
damit für eine drastische verbreitung
von ebola sorgten sie sind dann in alle
himmelsrichtungen ausgeschwärmt und
haben eben ebola verbreitet es reicht
eine solche person ein trainer eine
masseurin ein therapeut irgend jemand
der mit vielen menschen engen kontakt
hat und schon ist eine verbreitung kaum
noch aufzuhalten und dann helfen nur
ähnlich drastische maßnahmen wie in
china wir sollten darauf gefasst sein
deswegen müssen wir uns vorbereiten und
am besten die verhaltensregeln der wiro
befolgen die wurden nicht aus jux und
dollerei veröffentlicht es ist eine
ernste situation
wir haben zum corona virus eine playlist
erstellt hier könnt ihr immer die
aktuelle entwicklung verfolgen einfach
draufklicken wenn er unsere videos
zuerst bekommen wollt könnt ihr kanal
mitglied werden ab sofort bekommen die
kanal mitglieder für einen kleinen
beitrag die videos zuerst vor allen
anderen und wenn er kein video verpassen
wollt dann folgt uns auf telegramm
da bekommt ihr im gegensatz zu youtube
in jedem fall eine benachrichtigung wenn
ein neues video kommt corona virus was
bringt der mundschutz anklicken
anschauen und der medizinstudent
abonnieren super fundierter kann
bis dann bleibt dran